so this is manganese metal you know very
often in chemistry we use manganese and
in form of permanganate as an oxidizing
agent but this is manganese metal
manganese is right in the middle of the
row of transition metals and it has five
five electrons which can give it really
very rich chemistry so here you can see
it's a brand-new sample although the
bottle looks very very old is a hundred
grams so I'm going to pour a small
amount of manganese out so that we can
have a closer look one of the main uses
of manganese at the moment is as a
catalyst for making the plastic which
you find in plastic water bottles you
can see my big display of water bottles
up there and manganese is a key catalyst
in the reaction between xylene which is
the raw material that you get from crude
oil to make terephthalic acid which is
one of the components in this plastic
and the reason it's important is the
manganese can add and lose electrons
which help in the reaction between
xylene and oxygen it's this isn't paper
little manganese is also important in
old batteries the older sort of
batteries that you used in torches the
sort that leaked contain manganese
dioxide so here we have the manganese
and we're going to pour a small amount
out so that we can have a look at this
element and you can see the how the
color refract off that off the top
really quite lovely sample of the
manganese metal itself so we're looking
at manganese crystals growing from the
surface because this material would have
been a made from from a high-temperature
crystal growing type process so you can
see the manganese is growing and seeding
new crystallites on the surface and
seeding off in every direction it's cool